you're not gonna give me just a few
coins after everything I've done for you
what happened to the coins I already
gave you the ghost hunting business was
a sound investment Mario where you going
sit there and never say anything I carry
on every conversation oh my god whatever
I was the person that when I was any
place so hard you're just like your
mother what would you know dad you're
never home where do you think that money
in your ATM comes from or my battle
winnings dad oh sure I guess you know
everything about everything you say that
is just sing that link always wears the
same stupid outfit every day
yes Holly doesn't talk to that weirdo
tingle tingles on my head no he's still
playing the ocarina just all his puzzles
are you listening yourself maybe space
pirates wouldn't keep taking over zebus
if anyone besides me carried a zero
laser wow that's a really ignorant thing
to say
more weapons only lead to more boss
battles maybe in dreamland we're trying
in the real world at Samus you should
really read this article what happened
on Planet SEVIS is a hoax your
government is lying to you pika pika
pika pika pika pika Pikachu pika
you
please
Mario why can't you just teach me to
type I want to write letters we got a
race Mario we got a I got a race